well it's my pleasure to introduce David
Heenan he's the author of the book that
he'll be speaking about tonight flight
capital the alarming exodus of America's
best and brightest Dave is currently a
trustee at the estate for the estate of
James Campbell and for those of you who
might not know what this is this is one
of the nation's largest landowners and
has assets valued over two billion in
Hawaii mainly he has the the fortunate
that he is fortunate I should say to
live in Hawaii and in fact that's where
I first met David so he has kind of the
best of all worlds great job and a great
location he also served as an executive
of Citigroup not in Hawaii I assumed
this was in New York is that right in
New York and was chairman and CEO of the
Theo Davies company which is in Hawaii
they've taught at the University of
Pennsylvania's Wharton School of
Business and also at Columbia University
but most of his academic career was
spent as vice president of academic
affairs and Dean of the University of
Hawaii Business School two separate
roles that he had there as an industry
expert dr. Henan has authored and
co-authored several books including
double lives which was cited by Forbes
as one of the best business books in
2002 and he's been featured in numerous
publications including the New York
Times in the Harvard Business Review
Dave in fact has has written six books
that correctly written or authored or
co-authored six books and I want to say
a little bit about that because each of
these books as you as you look at them
if you could go in and and seek them out
on Google or whatever you'll find that
each book has a sort of a very different
topic area and this is one of the things
I find most impressive about David he
has a very inquisitive mind he's got a
very creative mind and questions pop up
for him and he goes out and does some
research on those questions and produces
a book like the one that you'll hear
about today and the and those questions
are varied across a lot of different
arenas his book
double lies for example examined of very
successful individuals who have dual
careers they have one career and then
they started another career and and some
very interesting findings there another
one was a book called co-leaders in
which he looked at what's the number two
person in the organization like to a
very great number one now how do you
survive and and function and motivate
yourself in that type of an environment
so as you can see these are kind of
different books in different arenas and
I think his his ingenuity and his
creativity as inquisitive nests up in
the work that he's done he received his
undergraduate degree from College of
William and Mary his MBA from Columbia
and his PhD at the University of
Pennsylvania this weekend not sure
whether it's Friday or Saturday he'll be
appearing on the PBS show foreign
exchange with Fareed Zakaria and I don't
know if any of you have ever watched
that that show but he'll be on it and
and hopefully that if you're interested
in the ideas he's presenting it evade
that you'll see you'll make time to see
that show that's it ladies and gentlemen
please welcome dr. David Heenan Thank
You Jerry
half of that was true actually delighted
to see you Aloha as we say in my country
or Mele Kalikimaka about this time of
the year I appreciate you all coming out
I guess this is the last session the ti
E and the Commonwealth Club will have
before the holidays and we certainly
appreciate your your hearty support I
want to thank Mateen and and T ie as
well as a Commonwealth Club in putting
this together Mary Bitterman my old
friend Bank of Hawaii and academic days
put me in touch some time ago with a
Commonwealth Club I've had the
opportunity to speak in San Francisco
this is my first time in the valley but
we nari and I are delighted to be here I
also want to thank in attendance this
evening my publishers Davies black right
up the road in Mountain View we've got
with us Jeff Hayes Lee Lang hammer law
and Laura Simons who have been
tremendously supportive of all of my
writing projects and I'm tickled to
death to see them here tonight our host
by the way in in the valley is another
distinguished author or a distinguished
author Nancy Kincaid tomi Nancy is with
Putnam you may have read her verbena her
balls a variety of her books a couple of
them have been transformed into the
silver screen she is married as you may
know to dick Tomey who happens to be the
football coach at San Jose State and he
allegedly is on a recruiting trip
tonight Nancy I'm not sure whether
that's really the case but he's not with
us he is in spirit and finally I'd like
to thank my co-author and co-leader and
that's my wife nari and I think many of
you during the intro session had a
chance to meet her she's a she's
something else if you if you haven't if
you haven't met her and we're hoping
she's not part of the flight capital
movement by the way this is an exciting
group it's an intimidating group I got
to tell you I mean very bright faces out
there I've never forgotten the great
line of the late comedian Georgie Jessel
who said the human brains a wonderful
device it starts up the moment you're
born and never stops do you stand up to
speak in public or appear in front of
c-span but I just had to be here tonight
to talk to you about this beautifully
written can't put it down
destined to be best-selling book which
is going to be flogged over there at a
knock off price of twenty seven dollars
when we finish I had a lot of fun doing
the book as we will see tonight you know
my old boss and mentor at Citicorp
Walter Wriston used to say that capital
always went word was welcomed and stayed
word was well treated by capital ristin
meant financial and human capital and of
course for years for centuries really
the United States was unequaled in
attracting both kinds without even
lifting a finger without even trying
hard we were able to pick off the first
round draft picks of country after
country the IM Pei
the Peter Drucker is the Albert
Einstein's the alfred hitchcock's unlike
any other country in the world this is a
nation of immigrants over the years we
have celebrated our immigrants we sing
about them we clearly rejoice in their
wonderful horatio alger success stories
nowhere perhaps more of those stories on
vivid display than right here in this
wonderful valley of crucible of
technology where immigrants have just
generated so much pizazz and buzz and
success and contribution not only to the
region but to our great country over
half of the PhDs working in the United
States came from another country 45% of
all of our computer scientists are
physicists or mathematicians immigrated
here one out of every four doctors Lady
doctors and heaven knows how many nurses
came from another country so I suppose
it's no great surprise no great surprise
that most Americans including yours
truly cling to the belief that this
really is the promised land a nation so
powerful it's a lure so magnetic that
anybody's seeking a better life would
necessarily want to come here that's a
perception that dies hard but about five
or six years ago from my perch in
Honolulu I started to notice a number of
foreign-born Americans many of them in
this country 10 20 30 years most of them
highly successful making a u-turn and
going back to their native lands that
trickle became a steady flow after 9/11
when I suppose it was perfectly
reasonable that the United States would
necessarily tighten up its immigration
and naturalization procedures but in the
processes this audience I know well
knows we were very clumsy about that and
created an unfriendly a frosty
environment towards not only potential
new recruits but recent arrivals by my
own back-of-the-envelope calculations
every day every day we are losing as a
country between 500 and a thousand very
gifted foreign-born Americans many of
them in
leading-edge professions in science and
technology and engineering and
entrepreneurship the underpinning of the
innovation economy
exactly exactly the kind of people you
want to keep your hooks on this reverse
brain drain or what I'm calling flight
capital and it's beautifully written
can't put it down best-selling book
seriously does I think have some
significant implications on both our
national security and our global
competitiveness because exactly when we
seem to be losing our long-standing grip
on imported talent we're also told that
our supply of homegrown talent is also
shriveling up survey after survey after
survey indicates that the United States
is in for a whopping labor shortage
particularly in knowledge oriented
sectors and while other countries are
extending the welcome mat to gifted
foreigners we regrettably seem to be
moving in the opposite direction and my
concern and hence the reason I wrote
this book my concern really is if we
aren't very very careful our great
nation of immigrants could become a
nation of immigrants for the last five
years I have been Criss crossing the
planet to visiting countries from India
to Ireland from Iceland to Israel
talking to some truly extraordinary
people who made the gut-wrenching and
very difficult decision to head back to
their native countries so I thought what
I would do this evening in this much
coveted after cocktails after dinner
slot would be to introduce you to just a
few of the players a few of the cast of
characters from the book but first I
think an important point of
clarification let's not let's not
confuse flight capital or losing very
brainy people without sourcing or simply
losing jobs outsourcing for all sorts of
reasons has become the boogeyman of the
times the issue I think is far more
complicated my own opinion outsourcing
is probably mildly positive for the
American economy in any case it's here
to stay and we couldn't stop at folks if
we wanted to
leaking talent leaking talent though is
far far more insidious than losing jobs
just think about it when a nation's best
brains walk they take with them not only
their intellectual capital but
invaluable context that they've nurtured
over a period of many many years under
the rosiest circumstances one would hope
that when these people go back home they
do so in the employ of the Microsoft's
and the Intel's of the world but as I
soon discovered those ties quickly fray
and most people when they were patriot
home actually do to do so to start their
own companies or join local employers as
your allegiances invariably shift to the
Nate of their motherland
yesterday's colleagues become tomorrow's
competitors and eventually eventually
that has to take a bite out of the
American economy it really I think is
that simple ok enough said let us start
our journey this evening tilting not
towards the Pacific but to the Atlantic
to the Emerald Isle of course over the
years over the centuries millions of
freckle-faced Irish men and women came
to that came to America in search of a
better life one of the byproducts of the
44 million Americans including yours
truly who claim to be partially Irish a
number I expect that blips up a little
bit around st. Patrick's Day Jerry
Denham II certainly had a better life in
mind when he snared a visa to work in
the United States it was like winning
the lotto he told me my sister lived and
worked in America and I had every
expectation every expectation of staying
indefinitely if not even permanently so
at age 29 is young but quite seasoned
hotel manager came across settled in the
Big Apple and quickly became part of a
management team tasked with opening the
beautiful Four Seasons Hotel in midtown
Manhattan but less than five years later
in a dramatic break from previous
generations of Irish immigrants to the
US one of the oldest the longest most
sustained
in flows in US history Jerry Dennett II
did the absolute unthinkable he went
back home in doing so he joined the
rising legions of Irish immigrants to
the US a group that my good buddy the
Irish economist John Fitzgerald calls
homing pigeons of people who literally
flocked back to the land of their birth
starting really in the late 1990s we
start to see more Irish men and women
returning home last year the country
actually took in 30,000 more people that
had sent abroad many of them like Denton
E homing pigeons from America I think
we've all heard in recent years about
Ireland's tremendous economic turnaround
it's now the high-flying Celtic Tiger
and certainly economics had a large part
in Dennehy's decision making but as I
found very often repatriation is much
more than sheer economics every Irish
man and woman he told me every single
one of us living overseas really and
truly wants to go back home he said we
all are vested with something we call in
Gaelic grah grah GRA it means a sense of
place a sense of belonging a love of our
home country well wanting to get a
better sense of Ireland's economic
rebirth and importantly the role that
these home and homing pigeons were
playing in it I contacted Enterprise
Ireland which is the country's economic
development agency and they said look
before you come across to Dublin you
really must you must stop off in New
York you see we have targeted life
sciences is one of our high-priority
future growth industries and we've
actually identified 400 Irish immigrants
to the United States working in the life
sciences field all of them have at least
a master's degree many of them have PhDs
and we've actually surveyed this gang
and 75% of them say they're prepared to
come back to the old sod within five
years so we're laying on this very very
fancy two-day conference in New York
it's called biolink Ireland
USA to try to entice some of these
people back to dear ol Island so here I
am folks two years ago in October on a
chilly day in the bowels of lower
Manhattan actually within the view plane
of the Statue of Liberty which of course
welcomes so many generations of Irish
immigrants to the US and I answer enter
this quite elaborate private club and
there are 280 of these scientists who
have been corralled into attending this
session and the Deputy Prime Minister
Mary Harney is the kickoff speaker and I
must say she had more piss and vinegar
in her than any public official I have
ever encountered and she tells this
group the Ireland that you folks left 10
20 30 years ago has changed dramatically
but we're still very much in transition
but we can no longer compete on cheap
labour I've been to India I've been to
China I've been to Eastern Europe I've
seen what they can do if we're gonna
survive in the years ahead it's going to
be on the backs of brainpower on people
like you and then with the Verve of the
most Evangel itical military recruiter
she looks this audience in the eyes and
says we want you and you and you we want
you all to come back home that we know
we can't get every one of you but we
really want to want you to seriously
consider consider returning home to
Ireland and for the next two days a
steady stream of speakers really echo
this patriotic plea the University Don's
captains of industry venture capitalists
people have actually made the trek back
themselves all of them were the same
plea y'all come come home to Ireland but
I must say the most powerful presenter
during this session was actually an
American the chief executive officer of
Wyeth the u.s. drug maker and he tells
the audience our company has been in
Ireland since 1974 slowly but surely
building up our base of operations three
years ago he says our board of directors
took a decision to build what we think
is going to be the most
advanced state-of-the-art
biopharmaceutical laboratories in the
world
it'll be 1.2 million square feet it's
going to cost our company 1.7 billion
dollars as you can imagine he tells them
every industrialized country on the
planet has been after us to locate there
but timing was a vivianne of the essence
we really wanted to get this baby up and
running quickly and we didn't want to
get bogged down with environmental
impact statements or difficult planning
councils and commissions and very
quickly we settled on Ireland but and by
the way got all of our all of our
approvals within a record six weeks just
two weeks later I had the opportunity to
see this mammoth facility under
construction it'll be up and completed
at the end of the year it will house
1,300 scientists and researchers about a
third of them returnees or homing
pigeons from the United States and
amazingly when you put all of Wyatts
in-country employees together this
single company is going to employ one
percent of the entire Irish national
workforce
I mean impressive stuff but while Irish
eyes are smiling I don't think most
Americans have an absolute clue the
extent to which other countries are
actively chirp cherry-picking some of
our best and brightest talent and I must
say for me it was a wake-up call well
from Ireland it was unto Iceland the
legendary land of Fire and Ice by the
way I'm not going to drag you through
eight countries tonight so rest easily
but I had heard how Iceland this tiny
country of just two hundred and ninety
thousand people on a per capita basis
now was one of the six richest countries
in the world and how thanks to its
returnees they were attempting to
diversify the economy Lessing lessening
and their dependence on fishing but the
guy I had expressly come across to see
was dr. Kari Stefansson
the poster boy of homing pigeons in
Iceland or should I say homing puffins
for the national bird you see
steffensen's company
decode genetics had been on a tear
recently identifying some of the genes
associated with some of the world's most
serious diseases in just a month before
my arrival and Rekha Vic they had found
the the gene associated and implicated
in stroke and this fellow Steffensen has
this mammoth dream of making this tiny
country the epicenter of genetic
discovery so here I am now it's in the
month of November at about nine o'clock
in the morning on a chilly windy rainy
foul day given its location the sun's
still trying to peep through the horizon
walking across this petrified lava
forest or field very much like parts of
my own state the Big Island with a smell
of sulfur pouring out of the ground
absolute boonies and there in the middle
of this nothingness is this spectacular
I mean spectac altra modern Scandinavian
style three-story structure the home of
300 scientists and researchers from 20
countries around the world about a third
of them homing pigeons from the United
States and I'm greeted warmly by this
Viking like six foot five inch
Steffensen who quickly gives me the
obligatory plant tour and then he
quickly gets down to business and tells
me right here right here is where we're
going to revolutionize modern medicine
we're going to find the cure for every
major disease right in this building
steffensen's and interesting guy is a 54
year old medical entrepreneur he
graduated at the top of his class at the
University of iceland's Medical School
and then it was off to the University of
Chicago for a postdoc and neurology and
neuropathology where he distinguished
himself over a decade and a half so much
so that Harvard came a-calling offered
him an endowed professorship in the
medical school but he always felt always
felt the tug of his home country and
it's very unique human database so just
three years later we're now in 1996
Steffensen and an American colleague guy
by the name of Jeff culture
up a business plan come right here to
Silicon Valley and walk away with 12
million dollars in venture capital to
start decode genetics four years later
the company raised another hundred and
seventy four million dollars on an IPO
on the Nasdaq and the rest is really
history now I didn't know many of you
know that Iceland for all sorts of
strange reasons has some very very
special advantages for DNA detectives it
has one of the most homogeneous
populations in the world it has a rich
tradition of oral history it has an
incredible record-keeping system its
public health department and on and on
but to access what's often been
described as a richest national genetics
laboratory in the face of the earth
Steffensen would need the help of his
government so when he went back home in
96 he approached the president you can
do this in a small country and the
Parliament and he said look if you guys
are really serious about diversifying
the economy and I think we can do
something major-league in genetics and
life sciences but to make that happen I
need access to the medical records of
every Icelander past and present in a
relatively sensitive stuff right you
imagine that request in the US well a
raging debate occurred amongst
bioethicists in Iceland nonetheless 18
months later the government awarded
decode genetics and exclusive 12-year
license for this information base for a
thousand years for a thousand years
Steffensen told me our tiny country has
suffered because of its isolation but
now thanks to the government's decision
modern technology were able to turn that
isolation into a major advantage in its
wreck of ik laboratory the company
decode genetics is able on an annual
basis to crank out 30 to 40 million
genotypes a year more than the rest of
the world combined its next leading
competitor which happens to be
Marshfield Clinic up in Wisconsin
can in its best days do about 8 million
a year a year nobody can compete with us
Steffensen brag to me he said in part
it's because it's Iceland and part it's
because of our technology and science
but in large part it's because of our
people they're every bit as good as
anybody you'll find in Boston or San
Francisco in fact as you've seen most of
them came from Boston or San Francisco
and you know he particularly bristles
when he recalls telling his Cambridge
colleagues several years ago that he was
heading back to Iceland he said my
friends said nobody I mean nobody in
their right mind ever walks away from an
endowed professorship at Harvard and for
Iceland what that you know what are you
thinking when I asked him if he's ever
had any second thoughts any regrets he
says nope Dave not for a moment he said
it may seem strange to you but this cold
barren windy treeless island is where I
was born for me it's home and it's been
home for my ancestors for 11 centuries
well of course Ireland and Iceland
aren't the only two countries trying to
make a name for themselves in life
sciences on the opposite side of the
world sits another mini state Singapore
which is probably even more ambitious
thanks to its father figure Lee Kuan Yew
Singapore has always has always relied
on imported talent to stay competitive
attracting foreign talent and recruiting
Singaporeans back home is in quote a
matter of life or death on close quotes
so says the current prime minister who
happens to be Lee Kuan Yew's son to that
end the government has set an objective
of having domiciled in Singapore by the
end of this decade 10 to 15 world-class
life sciences companies to make all of
that happen they have pointed up 1.5
billion dollars in our recruiting budget
and also to create this phenomenal
science city called by Appa --less some
of you may have seen it really is very
very impressive four years ago the
government poached Alan Coleman
the Scottish scientists of Dolly the
sheep Fame and with with Coleman a bunch
of other folks but their most impressive
recruit is probably an American dr.
Edison Lee you Lee you traded in his
directorship of the National Cancer
Institute in Bethesda to set up and run
the genome Institute of Singapore I had
the opportunity to visit him late one
to's rainy Tuesday afternoon when
workmen were still putting the finishing
touches on his phenomenal building which
is called appropriately enough the
genome part of the by Oppel is complex
by the end of last year he had recruited
a hundred and eighty to his team of
eventually 285 eighty-five percent of
his senior staff have come from abroad
including the entire gene sequencing
team which he which he lifted out of
Paris in a dozen high-level scientists
that came across from Bethesda Maryland
for Singaporeans going back home the
notion of getting their children in
touch with their roots their culture
their family and as importantly their
wonderful public school system our major
major draws many of them said you know
Dave we love the states we have many
friends back in America but frankly we
did not we did not want to raise our
children in the MTV generation thank you
very much many of them cited the dumbing
down of the corseting of America whether
it was increasing public vulgarity or
bare midriffs to them as being terribly
off-putting one scientist said you know
the day I discovered looking at my kids
middle school budget that we were
actually going to budget and spend more
on metal detectors than on mathematics I
came back and told my wife we're out of
here for Western is going across to
Singapore the opportunity to live in a
world-class City which it clearly is in
a very vibrant part of the world and
doing work working on leading edge
research seem to be the major incentives
unlike the United States Singapore
not only allows but it encourages
stem-cell research and stem cell
research is a huge portion of their
research portfolio Leo is an interesting
guy he is a Hong Kong immigrant to the
US as a child they came across settled
in the Bay Area attended Stanford later
taught there taught at Yale at Duke
before joining the National Cancer
Institute and to him the major appeal he
said is to was to build a multicultural
a multiracial multinational Laboratory
of the highest order he said Dave you
know except maybe for your Hawaii that
probably is no diverse a society as
Singapore and my wife and I really
wanted to raise our three children in a
multicultural environment but the big
question is when I asked him I says this
place really going to make the top tier
in life sciences I mean let's get real
here
and he said we'll make it we're small
we're fast we're flexible we can get a
decision out of the government a week to
ten days we're going to be one of the
major players by 2010
well Edison liew was just one of many US
citizens
u.s. citizens who were also part of this
flight capital movement another talented
turncoat and will be my last this
evening is Anna Maria Salazar one of 40
million Hispanic Americans in the United
States
interesting gal she was born and raised
in Tucson and shortly thereafter moved
to Mexico with her father her parents
her dad was a prominent cardiologist she
was quite a scholar quite an athlete she
actually swam on Mexico's national swim
team she was so good academically and
athletically she won a scholarship to
Berkeley distinguished herself there
went on to Harvard Law School graduated
from honors joined the US Foreign
Service and with was then posted to
several Latin American embassies came
back to to DC worked in the White House
worked in the defense and State
Department was the deputy assistant
secretary of defense for
drug enforcement was identified as one
of the hundred most influential Hispanic
Americans in the United States but four
years ago at age 41 she felt the tug of
Mexico her family and frankly greater
opportunity and went south of the border
to join a very prestigious think-tank
and shortly thereafter began producing
and starring in a very popular
television documentary series
she actually credits the much
beleaguered much much beleaguered Fox
administration with making Hispanic
Americans and expatriate Mexicans feel
at home
south of the border she said that wasn't
always the way it is but things have
changed today and and I I must say you
know Mexico on a ten-point scale ain't
in Ireland or in Israel or what-have-you
it's probably one and a half ABBA trying
hard and I was very very impressed
frankly with the numbers of very very
talented Mexican professionals and and
Hispanic Americans that are building a
new life for themselves in Mexico well
you know we're wrapping up now
four years four years the United States
had very little if no competition in
stockpiling Talent whether it was
homegrown or imported the Salazar as the
lose the steffensen's of the world I
mean we just it was it was a piece of
cake it was a crapshoot they they all
came here but in the ebb and flow of
globalization all the chips are in the
air all of the cards are in the air and
as Tom Friedman likes to tell us
repeatedly and very articulately the
world really is flat and if a country
really wants to invest in science
technology and education they can play
the global business game now having said
that let me in all honesty tell you
right up front that flight capital is
still a young phenomenon it's still in
its embryonic stages America is always
going to be a preferred haven for many
many folks from abroad the u.s. is
absolutely the best place on earth to be
a foreigner so told me the Dean of the
tell
leave law school who was taught at Yale
Harvard in Michigan said no place else
even comes close so Americans needn't
despair I mean we are capitalism on
steroids we have an awful lot going for
us but no country no country can afford
to rest on its laurels as we all know
from from business that's hot it's a
whole lot tougher to maintain one's
leadership than to get it in the first
place and their increasing number of
foreign countries and companies who are
today ready willing and increasingly now
able to cherry-pick some of our
brightest minds finally I would point
out as you no doubt have discerned this
evening that flight capital really is a
story of both good news and bad news
it clearly is good news to the extent
that there's a more equitable
distribution of brain power around the
planet that's a good thing a rising tide
one would hope lifts all ships and to
the extent that more countries and more
people are able to enjoy the benefits of
globalization that has to be a major
major positive nonetheless having said
that the reverse brain drain does pose
does pose some very serious challenges
for the unit for the United States if in
fact we live in a world where creativity
and innovation are key and I think we do
no nation no nation can afford to see
its best minds walk so this I think
really is a turning point it's a moment
of truth as somebody has once said the
history of man is the history of great
nations that came to catastrophic ends
because of their inability to react and
respond to major challenges historically
the United States has demonstrated the
ability to react to those challenges it
served us well in the past if we so
choose it will serve us well in the
future thank you very much Aloha
[Applause]
what happened to port
don't come later he's act 3 the old Zell
to last my I am good evening everyone
and thank you so much David for a really
very very interesting presentation which
has piqued everyone's interest in this
fabulous fabulous book I'm Mary
Bitterman president of the Bernard Osher
foundation member of the Commonwealth
clubs board of directors and a very
longtime friend of David Heyman we serve
on the Bank of Hawaii board together and
it's a wonderful experience he's not
only a great author but quite a wit a
number of people have been interested in
the characters that you have referenced
this evening and those who have actually
read the book before how did you
identify these people what process did
you go through to find just the right
person from each place well really
called a laundry list and I think simply
Mary through networking is as I got into
the topic folks like you all would would
point me in the proper direction and say
you absolutely must talk to Kari
Stefansson or ana maria salazar or a
number of these people there they're
really they're just so many interesting
stories out there I probably interviewed
about a hundred people in eight
countries but there there's there's
plenty out there I'm afraid to tell you
there's just a lot of you know very very
very touching and interesting stories so
many people have really introduced
questions variations on the following
theme and that is as you pointed out
this reverse brain drain but what
practical steps can the United States
take to really deal with this
essentially the recommendations in the
book which are in the last chapter
relate to sort of two dimensions one
really deals with the whole
immigration sort of series of issues
which many of you lived through I know
in this audience and trying to get our
immigration policy being right headed
once again everything from lifting the
h-1b visa thing to trying to get our
immigration people to do something
simple like smile at the airport a
little hospitality training would would
be in order and and the stories that I
heard and and I'm you know as we go
around the room here you you can you can
generate more than I can are absolutely
horrific so we really do have to to get
our act together in terms of being a
much more welcoming nation that means
really at a lower level recruiting more
foreign students here at our high
schools I know when you and I went to
high school there was always a plethora
of kids from abroad that that program
has really fallen into disarray I think
with with time demands and single
families and so forth our foreign
student population at the high school
level has gone down as you know within
the last two years it has also gone down
at the university level we really have
to get that up and up and running again
and become a more welcoming nation but
that's only half the loaf the other half
is that this would would be less of a
problem if we were growing our own
homegrown native-born talent but as many
of you know particularly those around
university life American kids are not
majoring in science math and engineering
they want to major in sports management
or broadcast journalism anything that
has a number two to a you know they
break out into the hives and somehow we
have to energize almost instead of a
post but Nick form interest in science
and engineering mathematics medicine and
so forth people clearly in this valley
Craig Barrett has been one of the most
Intel articulate champions of that Bill
Gates of course at Microsoft has been
out and about feeding the campuses
trying to stimulate that same interest
that's going to take time you know the
National Science Foundation in a
separate study said it will take us ten
years
at least to get back to where we were
relatively speaking in terms of our
reference representation in those key
fields in the 60s and 70s so we'll get a
long way to go it's going to be heavy
lifting one person raises the question
do you think that will ever be a point
when the majority of US college students
will be going overseas to study rather
than staying in the u.s. due due to the
fact that other countries are beginning
to invest more in their educational
systems especially with an emphasis on
science and technology I certainly hope
so you know as as a country only 4% of
the u.s. student population are from
abroad Switzerland in Australia both at
17% they're the highest two percentages
in the world but we're still woefully
underrepresented and I think there's a
lot of a lot of room to go in terms of
our own kids going overseas they they
appear Americans appear to be more
geographically adventurous today I think
the younger generation the study abroad
programs and so forth have been very
very helpful just on a personal note I
mean both of our kids did significant
stints one in Spain the other one more
importantly 10 years in Japan so that's
that's taking hold but we have a long
way to go I think but that that I think
is one of the antidotes to the sort of
dilemma that we're now in a number of
people have raised a question in the
selected stories we had the there was
just a desire to have something more
said about Greater China India Korea
maybe this is a chance for you to do
that well I can understand that
really the China and India stories
particularly this side gets an awful lot
of play and and so when I kind of get
out and about I like to like to
introduce some of the countries that
tend to be slightly off the radar screen
but you know the two the two major
countries that are really involved in
the flight capital movement are India
and China in terms of the body count the
head
as for all the obvious reasons
interestingly whereas some of the other
countries that I mentioned the
initiatives are really coming from the
public sector clearly in Ireland in
Israel and so forth there are major
government initiatives to go after the
kind of brainpower that that we've been
talking about in India and China the
initiatives have primarily come from the
private sector particularly in India
many of you know Kiran Myranda Shah at
Biocon you know she was very very clear
to point out to me in our interview she
said hey look the government has
absolutely nothing to do with this
return home movement she says in fact my
her feeling was that the government lust
for the repaid created earnings and the
remittances that come from overseas and
they probably want to keep more of our
folks back in the United States and
elsewhere just as long as the checks are
coming in she said the real role models
for bright young Indians coming back
home are people in Infosys and Wipro and
Tata and and and her good self so it
tends to be the magnetism tends to be
spurred by some of these individuals who
have built some colossal companies some
some very very successful companies as
opposed to any systematic government
role in the process mm-hmm
the the issue of education continues to
come up and more than one person raised
the question about any comments you
might have through the research that
you've done on the educational systems
in the countries from which people have
come to the United States but where
they've already brought a kind of
penchant for Science and Technology and
oftentimes much sturdier basic training
many of you read The Wall Street Journal
article of a week or so ago about
Cupertino high school and the fact that
thanks to its it's blended population
and an immigrant population they have
raised the bar to the point the point to
which many of the quote locals have
found it uncomfortable and decided to
move into easier school districts
very very interesting piece that led us
to the editors frankly of which which
appeared this week
or perhaps even more telling no these
these kids bring a wealth of knowledge
and competence a can-do attitude to the
process it's really energizing in fact
one of the secondary effects of the
flight capital movement which which we
talk about in the book are the fact that
when the brain power goes home when mum
and dad go home very often their
children they're very very gifted
children go back with them if you look
at USA TODAY's all-american all academic
team they have 1st 2nd and 3rd team over
the last 6 or 7 years you will find that
almost 2/3 of that group are the
children of first-generation immigrants
or people in this country on h-1b visas
work visas that is a very very brainy
group parents go back the kids go back
with them that's a significant loss but
these kids clearly do in a major way and
rich our school system the flip side is
when when these kids if they've been out
of touch with the Singaporean system the
Indian system and the Chinese system
what we used to call the old John Glenn
problem the re-entry problem of going
back to their home countries can be
absolutely treacherous and and you know
me one fellow in Singapore said you know
it it is just if if your child is sort
of over 10 or 12 years of age and they
haven't really really been challenged in
the United States for them to come back
and assimilate successfully into our
school system is damn near impossible
said most of them can't do it most of
them wind up going to the international
school or an American school in
Singapore they just think at that stage
there are at least two years behind
particularly in science math engineering
the question is not only the the
migration of people but the question of
do you think there will be a point where
US companies move their headquarters
overseas and what
that mean you've already mentioned the
Wyeth buildings such as substantial I
mean it's major plant in Ireland but
yeah I mean I this is sort of my bag
early on was the global corporation the
geocentric company where Passport
didn't count but ability did we still
aren't in a one-world environment today
but I think you will see more multiple
headquarters or dual headquarters
certainly we seem capital markets are
very fungible here most of these
companies are listed on ten or twelve
national exchanges if we can harmonize
pension benefits and tax requirements
and the like there will be increasing
mobility but clearly they you know the
notion of having dual or triple or
quadruple headquarters albeit ins many
headquarters I think is very much in the
cards I think we'll see more not less of
that people have noted that you have an
interesting resume truly a Renaissance
man
as you can see who sort of stands out
for you as a kind of hero in business oh
boy that's that's a toughy you know I
mean I'm I'm sort of often asked you
know who is my mentor role model and
frankly they're you know I can't think
of any individual person but I've been I
think like a lot of you influenced by
professors that I've had over the years
certainly Walter Wriston at Citicorp was
a globalist extraordinaire very very
interesting a man of the world he had
significant influence in me but I think
every day I run into more people and
we'll this evening that will have an
important part in reshaping where I want
to go next
you you mentioned in your comments that
you know the life was made difficult for
many sort of recent arrivals to the
United States and people who were aiming
to come in the wake of the disaster of
9/11 and just wondering if you might
share a few more of your thoughts
regarding that yeah I you know I think
we are the nation of immigrants and I
think we we sort of take it for granted
that people easily assimilate here and
just sort of fall right into things and
I think for the most part people do do
quite a quite a good job of doing that
by the way I was talking to a Swedish
audience and they said look you know in
the States
anybody can assimilate within maybe two
or three years they said you know in
Sweden two to three hundred years before
you really understand so you know the
genius of America has been the ability
to assimilate people I mean anybody can
open the doors and you can have wide
open immigration but getting stuck into
the place I mean this is a nation of
immigrants people these folks really are
our heroes and and nonetheless I think
you know we we have created at the
company level there are glass ceilings
or a bamboo ceilings that many of the
people that I talked to ran into and for
them the solution was to go back home
and set up their own own businesses
their own companies they felt that they
really hadn't had run into some
difficulty I think companies have to be
much more aware that I think mentor
systems within industry are helpful I
think we also have to look at the family
members who who may be having some
issues I mean this again back to the
visa issue the trailing spouse problems
of I mean incredibly talented spouses
who are unable to find employment we I
mean we need to we're short 250,000 math
and science teachers in the United
States there are significant numbers of
these people that could from day one in
the King's English add a double dollop
of skill to the classroom and and
they're frozen out that's crazy
these are issues we ought to be dealing
with just a quick word on your views as
to how the current administration in
Washington views flight capital yeah I
mean I'm asked that how anybody I thank
the troubled Mary with this particular
issue and this is try to be as
bipartisan as I can be it frankly has
been buried between two other issues one
I mentioned earlier on and that's
outsourcing very very juicy debate for
the Falls whether it was Benedict Arnold
companies in the last election or
what-have-you
politicians on both sides really jumped
into that one now we have the you know
the border wars the illegal immigration
issues lou dobbs god bless him who I
think is as misplaced on in this thing
is just you know beating a dead horse to
death is is you know is trumpeting that
that has taken a lot a lot of attention
and what we've missed is this you know
this gray mass in the middle of
tremendous brain power the kind of
talent that that one really rut
leverages an economy and a country over
that are being neglected and and and
we've got to get get the focus back on
people like I mean everybody from
Kennedy to John McCain are very much
into this issue as is by the way our
senior senator Dan Inouye from from
Hawaii has been active in this but
generally it again has been morphed by
these other two concerns there's so many
questions and I know as people gather
with you over here for book signing and
whatnot they'll be able to ask
additional questions but we've come to
that part in the program where I have to
ask formally the last question and it's
this if you could share with us just a
fact of figure maybe but a couple of
them that were just quite surprising to
you as you went into this research try
this one
Bangu I knew he would have this
Bangalore India talking to the head of
the public school system city of almost
5 million people
a couple of years ago their kids were
set to take the SAT test there was a
mixup the exams did not reach India the
fellow called ETS in Princeton New
Jersey said here's my problem but I
happen to have the Graduate Record exam
and math science and engineering can I
give them to these kids there was a
pause on the other end and the guy
basically said if you want to bust their
pick be my guest
average score average score high school
juniors public school system major
metropolitan area 98 percent that's
that's the game that we're in and I
think again most folks don't have a clue
sort of where we are and and the kind of
heavy lifting that has to be done
collectively by putting our talents in
tandem and getting on with it well now
about to carry back to you Jerry is back
well thank you very much ladies a round
of applause for both Dave and Mary
thanks again for for really a very
interesting evening an interesting topic
interesting questions I appreciate all
of you coming and I now formally adjourn
this session of the T ie and Common
Wealth Club Silicon Valley session there
you go bang bang bang I don't have my
mat here we go thank you again and David
will be signing